Francia celebra la clasificación de su
selección a la final del mundial de
fútbol título que disputará a Argentina
este domingo mientras las dos
selecciones comienzan ya a prepararse
para el encuentro Tenemos reporte de
nuestro enviado especial a doja
en Reino Unido las enfermeras están en
huelga para exigir mejores salarios y
condiciones laborales los sindicatos
estiman que más de 100.000 trabajadoras
del Sistema Nacional de salud británico
se sumaron a las protestas
y siguen las protestas en Perú desatadas
por la detención del expresidente Pedro
Castillo acusado de rebelión El
Ejecutivo de Dina boluarte confirmó ocho
muertos en las manifestaciones y en
respuesta planteó adelantar las
elecciones para 2023
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más déu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos esta edición
también con información deportiva porque
tras la victoria de Francia sobre
Marruecos empezaron los preparativos de
cara ya a la final de este domingo que
enfrentará a la selección francesa
contra la Argentina un partido en que se
verán las caras los dos jugadores más
destacados del mundial hablamos de
kilian mbappé y de Lionel Messi
previamente nuestro enviado especial al
Mundial de Qatar Juan pupiales no
reportaba Cómo se preparan ambos equipos
para el último encuentro de esta copa
mundo
ya comienza el entrenamiento de la
selección argentina aquí en doja el
primero la primera sesión pensando en
esa gran final contra los franceses y
con ese sueño de levantar su tercera
copa mundo los argentinos que vienen de
una sesión de descanso después de
haberse impuesto sobre los croatas la
selección dirigida por Lionel escalón y
que aprovecha ese día más de preparación
que tienen respecto a sus rivales para
esa final tras haber jugado su semifinal
un día antes que el combinado galo el
combinado de DIRECTV precisamente que
realicé hoy una jornada de recuperación
después de esta Victoria contra los
marroquíes en semifinales por 2 a 0 se
habla mucho en la selección francesa de
esos reportes de la prensa europea que
señalan que Karim Benzema el Balón de
Oro regresaría para disputar esa final
contra los argentinos al respecto se le
preguntó por supuesto al seleccionador
después de ese triunfo contra el equipo
africano dijo de sham que no quería ni
siquiera responder a esa pregunta
Respecto a los otros equipos Croacia
Marruecos que tuvo una sesión de
descanso en esta jornada y Croacia que
sí realizó entrenamiento Croacia y
Marruecos que disputan el sábado ese
partido por el tercer puesto volviendo a
la final se espera que para ese partido
vuelva el presidente Emmanuel macron
nacer en la grada el mandatario que
defendió su visita aquí en Qatar en
medio de las acusaciones y críticas por
parte de la oposición en Francia se
desconoce si su homólogo Alberto
Fernández realizará lo mismo desde la
presidencia del país sudamericano No
aclararon si finalmente Fernández
viajaría aquí a Qatar en medio de una
política de austeridad Respecto a los
viajes por la que pasa el gobierno
sudamericano
cambiamos de información vamos a
Bruselas donde los líderes de la Unión
Europea se reúnen este jueves con dos
grandes frentes abiertos por un lado
Cómo hacer frente a la situación
económica derivada de la inflación y de
la crisis energética por las sanciones a
Moscú los 27 están divididos en acordar
Hasta qué punto las medidas deben
adoptarse en conjunto por otro lado está
también la gestión del llamado
qatargate el caso de corrupción
recordemos que vincula altos
funcionarios europeos con el cobro de
sobornos por parte de Qatar a cambio de
influir en las decisiones europeas a
favor de la monarquía del Golfo tras la
destitución de la ex vicepresidenta de
la eurocámara Eva Kylie una de las
presuntas implicadas en la trama la
Unión Europea plantea ahora nuevas
medidas de control para evitar nuevos
escándalos de injerencia extranjera
escuchemos a la presidenta del
parlamento europeo sola
en primer lugar por supuesto estos
procesos penales que involucran al
parlamento son perjudiciales
para la democracia para Europa y para
todo lo que representamos
la confianza que ha llevado años
construir pero solo unos momentos para
destruir tendrá que ser restaurada
reconstruida y ese trabajo comienza
ahora
en el Reino Unido el personal de
enfermería del servicio nacional de
salud empezó la primera huelga de su
historia las enfermeras exigen mejores
salarios y condiciones laborales así
como más contrataciones según los
sindicatos 100.000 trabajadoras
participan en las protestas de este
jueves en Inglaterra Irlanda del Norte y
gales Laurel tiene los detalles en el
siguiente informe
Es la primera vez que las enfermeras
británicas salen a la calle desde la
fundación de su sindicato
nos hemos visto empujados a esta
situación ahora mismo estamos en huelga
y Habrá más huelgas tenemos que
reconocer que no estamos aquí por
elección y que no hemos hecho esto por
capricho fácil
piden una subida hasta la real de
alrededor del 19% para compensar años de
carencias argumentan que los bajos
salarios se traducen en escasez de
personal y en una atención precaria para
los pacientes el gobierno conservador se
ha mostrado implacable prometiendo
legislar para reducir el poder de los
sindicatos y negándose a reabrir las
negociaciones me traen en una habitación
me dicen que puedo hablar de cualquier
cosa menos de salarios cierran sus
libros no ponen ni un céntimo marrón más
sobre la mesa y se marchan y dan la
espalda a la profesión
un pulso que tuvo también lugar el
miércoles en el parlamento entre el
líder una posición laborista quiere
estar mejor y el Primer Ministro
señor presidente que las enfermeras
estén en huelga es una vergüenza para
este gobierno en lugar de mostrar
liderazgo está jugando con la salud de
la gente
si él cree que es justo que se cumplan
las reivindicaciones salariales del 19%
que lo diga lo que es débil señor
presidente Es que él no es lo bastante
fuerte para enfrentarse a los sindicatos
el Reino Unido sumido a una crisis del
coste de la vida vive un momento de dar
atención desde los ferroviarios y el
servicio postal Hasta la policía de
fronteras se enfrenta a una oleada de
huelgas este invierno
cerramos con información de nuestra
región porque siguen las protestas en
Perú a pesar de la declaración de estado
de emergencia por parte de la nueva
presidenta del país Dina boluarte los
manifestantes argumentan que el
expresidente Castillo detenido
preventivamente y acusado de rebelión
fue víctima de las élites de Lima tras
confirmar ocho muertos en las protestas
El Ejecutivo planteó adelantar las
elecciones a 2023 en lugar de 2024 como
había anunciado inicialmente Rafael
Pérez nos amplía los reclamos de los
manifestantes
Qué piden los manifestantes en Perú
el cierre del legislativo el mismo que
los inconformes culpan de la
inestabilidad que vive el país
suramericano seis presidentes han caído
en medio de pulsos con el congreso
dominado por la derecha en al menos
cinco años con la salida de Pedro y la
derecha cree que se solucionó la crisis
se equivoca rotundamente no ha hecho más
que agravarse y entrar en un capítulo en
otro grado la liberación de Castillo es
otra de las exigencias el ex mandatario
se encuentra en prisión preventiva
mientras es procesado por presunta
rebelión y conspiración al intentar la
disolución del parlamento nosotros vamos
a continuar hasta que nuestro presidente
se ha puesto en libertad Otro aspecto
clave es la conformación de una asamblea
Constituyente su objetivo sería reformar
la Constitución específicamente lo
referido a la vacancia presidencial por
incapacidad moral un lineamiento creado
para sacar del poder a un mandatario por
inconvenientes de salud pero que el
congreso no ha dudado en utilizar como
arma contra varios presidentes Alberto
fujimori y Martín vizcarra han sido
blancos de esta jugada política también
piden la renunciar del actual presidente
Dina boluarte designada por el hemiciclo
peruano para sustituir a Pedro Castillo
era una antigua partidaria del ex
presidente y hoy considerada traidora
Por quienes piden un cambio nosotros
estamos pidiendo no de que la renuncia
inmediata de las de la señora
que ha usurpado con no ha cumplido con
todo el procedimiento legal para asumir
ese cargo la actual mandataria intentó
calmar las manifestaciones pidiendo al
congreso que adelante las elecciones
otro de los reclamos que Hasta no ver
materializado los seguidores afirmaron
que continuarían en las calles eran
cometido una tremenda injusticia han
atentado magia contra el presidente
Pedro Castillo han atentado contra la
voluntad popular les tenemos que
defender la democracia aquí y darle una
lección a todos estos golpistas los
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas del
orden y los manifestantes impulsaron al
nuevo gobierno a declarar el estado de
emergencia nacional durante 30 días
así llegamos al final de esta edición a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención sigan con nosotros
[Música]